so we'll start with this demonstration
so meanwhile i'll just share my screen
so that we'll start with what is
analytics probably this particular
session is to
get you an idea about what is analytics
and what are the things that we are
going to see in this particular course
so meanwhile if you have any questions
to us you can just talk to me
and then you can just throw your
questions regarding this particular
course so i'll try to answer all your
questions so
in this particular course this is mainly
we are going to see what is basically
analytics and we are going to see what
are the tools that we are going to
implement in terms of analytics and how
what are the applications it across
domains it is being applied so these are
all the things that we're going to
discuss today
yeah so let me take through the course
contents and uh what is this course and
what are all the things that we are
going to discuss here in this particular
course
see basically in this particular course
we are going to see what is analytics
and uh what are all the places where
analytics is being played so we'll be
looking at uh what are all the different
applications that analytics has and
overall the statistical algorithm which
is going to help you in doing all this
analytics process so the entire
structure is made in such a way that it
adds value to both research people as
well as business people because many of
the time the business people it is very
difficult for them to understand the
statistical part and sometimes all this
research people they are good at
statistical part but they find difficult
to relate it with business so
this particular course that we had
created is in such a way that it covers
both business as well as stacks so it
becomes easy for working professionals
so
here mainly uh these analytics concepts
we are going to see only in three tools
which is our sas and excel so these are
the three
three main tools we're going to see in
this particular course
okay so and we're not going to discuss
about any other tools
so i'll just take you through the
process of what is analytics so just a
basic introduction about analytics okay
and well if you have any questions or
any other doubts you can just ask me you
can just ping your questions in the chat
box so that i can just respond to you
back okay so any idea about uh what is
analytics
so generally people nowadays talk a lot
about analytics and data so do you have
any idea about what is analytics and why
actually you people are interested in
taking up this course so that's the
reason you are like sitting here and you
are listening to this particular
demonstration so can you just tell me
like why
what is analytics and why this makes
people interesting any area about
analytics just let me know your answers
according to your first selection so
i'll just try to put it in the way that
this course is made
okay
so
ravi you answered that to do an analysis
on business problems okay yeah and uh
shivam you're telling finding out raw
data to valuable data okay and ruby
again analysis yeah the simple thing uh
whatever you
whatever you told is something relevant
so in this current scenario if you're
looking at every domain has a lot of
data with themselves and people doesn't
know what to do with their data so
as an analyst or as a data scientist we
people what we're trying to do is we are
trying to get all this data and we're
trying to derive possible insights which
is going to help business because uh it
is not that i knew statistics i am not
going to do i am doing some algorithm i
am throwing the result so that is not
the case because whenever you do a
process at last it should make some
business relevance so that is what we
are going to see in terms of analytics
uh it is something a mixture of both
statistical plus business so you cannot
reject any one of this part and you
cannot you can never get into statistics
or analytics so it is very essential as
a domain expert or to become a data
scientist you need to know what is
business and what is statistics so we
had made a structure in such a way that
people gain both of these things
together okay so we're going to learn a
lot about data so initially if you're
looking at every domain has its own data
we're going to see how these datas are
being turned out and how these insights
are being derived out of this data so it
is something like every data has an
untold story so which an analyst as an
analyst we're trying to figure out those
story and we're trying to apply in your
business to gain good profitability okay
that's what you're going to
see here and in this particular course
we are going to see uh what is this data
transformation say if i have a raw data
how i'm going to process it every domain
has a data which is unclean so we're
going to see how these data comes into
the picture and how we are going to
clean this to derive a good insight so
in this particular scenario we are going
to discuss about
four different stages so every analytics
will have obviously four different
stages in it and these are the four
stages that we're going to cover here so
it always starts with a descriptive
point so i'll just tell you these are
all the four things which we are going
to discuss in a complete course
structure so i'll just take you through
each and every stages so that you would
get an idea so why we are doing all the
stages and what is the necessity of
doing all the stages okay so whenever
you get a data what is the first thing
that you will try to do for example you
have a raw data okay the first thing is
as an analyst or as the human being what
is the first thing that you're trying to
do out of this data everything's related
so the question that i throw you is the
same process that you're going to
implement in your course
so if i give you a raw data what is the
first thing that you try to do and what
is the first thing will
get in your mind there is a huge data in
in your database so you are going to do
some analysis so what is the first thing
that you will try to do so i'll just try
to give you an idea how to go ahead with
this process
okay
so any idea
if there is a huge data with with you
where you will start or how you will
start any idea about it okay with there
you are telling uh you're going to
arrange this data so obviously
if there is a raw data which is coming
to your place where you have to start an
analytics process or a project the first
thing is obviously you try to arrange
all your data and then what you try to
do is you will try to figure out what
are all the basic things that i can
understand from the data so if it is
unclean obviously i have to clean my
dataset and then i have to understand my
data at a basic level at a very basic
level what is my data and how these
datas are being represented say for an
example in business or industrial cases
there would be like uh
five tvs of data where you will have
hundred columns and uh crores of rows so
in that you have to derive at least a
basic insight out of the data as a
description so that is what we'll be
doing many process in terms of
descriptions both in our or any other bi
tools so there will try to put up all
these tools to understand the basic
level of data okay okay and ravi you
said based on the business problem we
have to do that and start doing your
analysis so just assume that i have a
business problem and these are the four
steps you are going to apply in that
business problem see uh i'll take you
through the next uh
upcoming slides i'll tell you the
business problems as well so first we'll
try to understand this course structure
then i try to tell you what all the
applications that it can have okay so
the first thing that always people would
know or interested in this to understand
the basic level of data so once i get a
clear picture okay this is my data then
what i'm going to do
for an example just uh let me throw you
a question so if you're telling that
how i'm going to predict a quantity or a
demand say i'm holding a e-commerce
company okay so there are a lot of
products in my inventory so i want to
see what is the product and how it is
going to behave in future okay so this
is one problem statement that we'll take
and we try to solve it okay how i'm
going to optimize my inventory so at
what level i should maintain my
inventory so for doing this
for
predicting your demand what are all the
possible factors that you can think of
say for an example i have to predict my
products demand how it is going to
behave in future
for doing this particular process what
are the possible things that you can
take into consideration say i'm going to
sell a product okay i'm selling a
product
and uh if i ask a question i'm selling
an ice cream so how the sales of ice
cream would be in future okay a simple
question so what are all the factors you
would consider that ice cream chips is
getting affected okay the production the
product cost okay that is one factor
yeah obviously schema said quality okay
and what else okay the marketing team
that you have because you would have lot
of good promotion so that you can just
attract the groups to your particular
product
and what else okay the good location so
where i hold my particular shop whether
i'm just holding it in an urban area or
a rural area
that is also one good thing and
obviously the sales figure okay how it
was during the past and you can also
consider many other factors say i could
tell temperature because depending upon
the temperature my sales of ice cream
would differ and it also varies
according to seasons yeah as uh price
compared flashy set price compare is
something your competitor analysis so my
competitor is pricing less than of
multi-cell so in that case obviously i
cannot make a good profit that is also
one good thing to consider yeah
competency in market
and what is you can also consider your
gdp inflation all microeconomic factors
and macroeconomic factors so if you are
considering okay innovative idea of many
flavors to attract people yeah so right
now i throw to your particular question
regarding the sales of ice cream and you
have n number of factors which is
causing an impact to your series right
so in terms of analysis it becomes
difficult whenever you are getting into
a business process you will find
thousand variables which is trying to
impact your sales so in that case how we
are going to differentiate it if there
are thousand variables if all the
thousand variables are going to crack my
sales that would be your first question
that will get into your mind so to
answer all these things people would
generally do a diagnostic so that they
try to figure out so if there are
thousand variables with my data set what
is the relationship between these
thousand variables so if i'm able to
establish a clear relationship with all
these factors then it makes sense for me
to predict the picture values so if i
tell okay temperature is having 15
percent effect and
price of the product is having 20
percent impact so based on this
relationship it is easy for you to
predict the future values right so
that's what the relationship of these
variables are being captured in terms of
diagnostics and this is the second page
that we're going to discuss and there
are a lot of statistical algorithms
which is being discussed in diagnostic
with the business applications okay and
next comes your third part which is
predictive so obviously now in the
second page you understood what is the
necessity of taking all this variable
and what is the relationship between all
these variables now after establishing
the relationship
is it possible for you to predict the
picture values
see right now i have hundred variables i
know all these hundred variables impact
towards my sales with a pin point
accuracy i have a proportion value which
is representing my sales and after
figuring out this numerical value
is it possible for me to predict the
future values
any guess
one say okay
yes but not exactly so if i tell that
okay temperature is having exactly ten
percent impact and price is having
twenty percent effect say if i have a
proportion telling the equal impact on
sales then it is possible right if i
have a numerical figure to represent it
and if i'm able to relate a causal
effect here then it is easy for me to
predict the future values so in this
particular third phase we are going to
see what all the forecasting algorithms
are what are all the predictive advanced
predictive techniques which is being
obtained so statistically we will learn
all these things so it tells me what is
going to be my future okay so now i have
figured out
what is the relationship and what is my
future now i figured out that my future
is going to be uh like it is going to
hold less sales okay the demand that i
hold this
so if you're looking at the last phase
this is something called prescription so
now that you are very clear about the
relationship of your variables and you
are able to predict your future values
and you you found that your future sales
is going to be down so what are all the
possible things that you can try to make
your business scary for example you
figured out that okay by upcoming months
the demand is going to be less so in
that case what would be your action
points in a business scenario now we are
able to figure out that my future sale
is going to be done okay using my
predictive model techniques i had
figured out what is going to be my
future and i had figured out that my
picture is going to drip down so which
is moving decline okay i found that okay
in the upcoming years like 2017 or 18 my
sales is continuously getting decreased
okay in this situation what are all the
possible things that you could think of
to make your business steady because at
the end of the day business is all about
gaining profit it is not about getting
lost right
so in this case what are all the
thought process that you would improve
there or you will try to implement there
okay need to find out factors which are
reason for the loss so these things are
being answered from your diagnostic or a
predictive model so your predictive
model would tell okay these are all the
factors which is trying to affect my
business so possibly if you are able to
understand your factors now is it easier
for you to take a decision right say for
an example people are reacting negative
towards my price so whenever i increase
my price people are reacting negatively
towards it which i found during my
analysis of predictive or diagnostic so
now that i can take a action right so i
can just try to reduce my price of my
product and i can do a marketing
campaign i can see how these are having
an impact so based on all these things i
can optimize my business and i can make
it steady right so that is where your
prescriptive part comes in and it
differs for all the other business so
we're going to discuss all these things
with all possible real-time case studies
because these applications are vast in
different domains and we are going to
see uh at least we will be discussing
four different domains by using all
these analytic stages okay
okay uh you're asking a question can you
please repeat prescription prescriptive
part is something which you are going to
take a decision or you are going to make
an implementation for example during
your process of predictive or diagnosis
you have figured out the practice which
is making your business go down okay say
in that case because your marketing team
is not able to establish a good exposure
towards advertisement or the price which
you had made for your product is not
satisfying your customer so these are
all the things that you have figured out
so that is going to make yourself go
down in the situation what you try to do
you try to either your factors right you
would
you would bring in a better marketing
team you would make your marketing
strategies in a better way and you will
also try to optimize your price so that
you are trying to attain a good
profitability right so these are all the
actions that you can easily take when
you are going ahead with all these three
process so these are the four stages
which we are going to see in both are as
well as and there are different
statistical algorithms which is going to
contribute for all these phases okay and
we're going to see some business case
studies where all these questions are
how it is getting solved this is the
process that we are going to follow in
our entire course structure and we are
splitted into descriptive diagnostic
predictive and prescriptive so there are
different statistical algorithms which
is contributing to each and every phase
which we'll try to see in detail with a
good case study of different uh retail
set uh like there are four different
sectors we have case studies uh one is
for healthcare retail and internet as
well as for for another sector so we'll
be looking at all these examples for all
possible sectors okay clear till this
point do you have any questions to ask
is our core structure clear because we
are trying to relate with each and every
step so that you would get an idea of
what it what is the data and how to
transform it and how to go ahead with
the process so we'll be dealing with the
end-to-end process of analytics so
however and clear data is getting
processed and at last how you should
deliver a result which makes sense for
business so these are all the things
that we are going to discuss in this
particular course lecture and i can tell
you uh the vast applications of
analytics so if you're looking at the
applications of analytics it is like
very very vast whereas
it is mainly updated in all the domains
whatever domains that you see everywhere
data analytics is being applied so you
can never see a domain without analytics
so i can tell you the process i'll tell
you what all the business cases are the
business application that we'll be
seeing
and we'll be looking at the cycle of
analytics so how our analytics process
should go and what are all the cycles
which is there so it details with all
this data and what is the data and how
it is being dealt with so we'll be
looking at all these possible factors
here
and we'll also look at different
examples of these analytics and what are
all the places that is being applied and
how it is being applied and these all
these processes are being handled using
our styles and excel so we'll be uh
we'll be covering with all these three
tools so right now i'll just try to tell
you some examples or some case studies
which we are looking in our particular
course lecture
so if you're looking at the applications
of analytics it is vast as i told you
earlier
uh in case of retail we have and the
application analytics something like uh
if you want to make a good promotion
there so what sort of promotion that you
can make to your customers or if you
want to optimize or maintain your
inventory it is necessary for you to
predict your future demand so how
exactly you are predicting your future
demand so that you can reduce your
inventory cost so all these things will
be discussing and these are all the
applications in retail sector and there
are a lot of applications in healthcare
as well like drug interactions and
disease management and uh when coming to
financial services you will try to
figure out what is the credit score
modeling or fraud detection pricing and
these are all the basic applications
which is being dealt here and there are
certain case studies which is being
provided for all this particular problem
and how analytics is being applied in
manufacturing industry as well as energy
industry so these are all the phases
which we'll be covering in our
particular course okay so do you have
any questions in this point okay uh what
about automobile so automobile case
studies are not available but if we have
a specific questions to ask in terms of
automobile because we have experts in
these domain instruments so they can
answer the question or if you are
working in an automobile project or
something
if your domain is automotive in that
case people are there to help you yeah
obviously telecom is there so when
coming into communication telegram is
also dealt with so people would give you
all the explanations and they'll tell
you some case studies applied for
different sectors because it is
impossible for us to cover all this
sector so most probably our case studies
will be related to retail health care
and
some of the financial services so and
apart from that if you have any domain
related specific questions we have
experts to solve it because everywhere
the problems are same and somehow you
are trying to apply your statistical
algorithms to solve your business
problem so in that particular phase if
you have any doubts we have experts to
solve it any other questions and these
are all the common uh applications which
we are taking up we have some case
studies related to some statistical
algorithm which we'll be showing in our
class as well as we provide you some
case studies with solution which you can
solve by yourself and you can just learn
it and if you have any questions uh
people are there to help you out and we
have a simple talk forum as well so
whenever you have question uh for every
budget we'll form a separate group
whereas during the session or after the
session if you have any question you can
post there so that all our trainers are
engaged there they'll be able to answer
all your questions okay
how do we formulate data which is in raw
condition so you are telling you are
asking how i can clean this data right
is that your question if i have an
unclean data how i can start with so all
these things are being covered in our
course so there is a raw data in your
place what to start with and where to
start with because there are certain
basic cleaning stuff which is to be done
which we'll cover in our session
and after that we'll try to tell you
how there is a relationship built
between the tables that you have say
when you are talking about industry it
is not about only one table in your data
there are almost like 100 or 200 tables
you would have how we are going to map
all these tables and what is the
relationship between all these things so
whenever we get into case studies uh you
will have such kind of problem which
we'll solve in the sessions okay so that
you will get a good idea about how to
clean my data and how to start a process
for analysis okay the first step is
obviously cleaning your data which we'll
be handling here okay okay any other
questions
now you can just ask your questions so
probably
if you are in a java domain or something
how it will take up this post and what
is
going to add value in my particular
domain so if you have these sort of
question you can just ask me and if you
have any core structure related question
you can just ask me so that i can just
clear that out okay do you have any
question okay today you had a question
what is the role of programming skill
needed in this week okay good question
so
this particular course is made in such a
way that even programming person or even
if there is a person who is from the
database or if there is a person
completely out of this id field even
they can learn this particular course
because we concentrate on business
statistics plus less coding stuff which
will try to
which will try to make you understand
the whole structure and i would suggest
coding skill is required but not that
that much because all the algorithms
that you're going to work with had
default libraries so that you should be
aware what is it algorithm and how
you're going to apply it so if you're
looking at the coding steps of r or sas
it is very simple and you can just learn
it very easily
okay and for this particular thing you
will not be an expert in coding
just a logical skill
only that is required in terms of
analytics
okay
nr is something which is completely
coding but not a very difficult coding
part it is very simple to understand and
uh it is actually an easy framework to
work on
okay what is the critical skill needed
so if you're asking me the critical
skill needed i would suggest a logical
thinking how you're trying to think
about business and how you're going to
apply all the statistics to your
business so that is the only thought
that an analyst should have
so you should be
good and understanding business problem
as well as you should be good in
understanding the statistical algorithm
so if you are able to understand both
this domain it is easy for you to
connect and to get better results okay
okay uh shivan can you please give some
example of r during this session okay
you're telling uh i should give an
example of our how this r tool works
right is that a question shivam okay uh
right now i don't have r in my mission
because i as it is a demo i don't have
that in my foreign mission so what i can
do is uh if you want to help or
we'll try to post in our community
probably by tomorrow we'll just try to
take the snapshot of some of the basic
uh our coding stuff we'll try to show
you the environment how it would look so
and what i can do there okay
it is something like a console so
whenever you open a command prompt it is
the same way that you are convoluted
so that is a place where you would work
to populate all your results and to
throw all your graphs it is same as your
command prompt so you'd be putting all
your comments in okay uh and whether you
had a question what kind of okay uh
before getting into another question i
just try to solve
this question first okay what kind of
assignment can come in this world when
on job okay you are asking uh when you
take up this course what sort of
assignments are how it is related to
your job
what is your question today okay you are
asking okay uh the simple thing is we
talk about some business problems here
at english session which you can relate
it with your business forum say for an
example if i talk about forecasting so
forecasting something we are trying to
predict future values which is an which
is a particular thing which is upgraded
in all the domains if you're looking at
retail sector or if you're looking at
energy sector or health care in all this
predicting your future value is one
thing which is very very important so
those things are being covered in a
curriculum so which is like a common
problem for all these actors uh most of
the case studies that what we take is
something which is applied across all
these efforts so we'll have case studies
in such way so that uh by doing up all
this case studies and uh by going
through all these algorithms it becomes
easier for you to implement the same
thing in your respective domains okay
because we take problem in such a way
that it is relating with all other
domain so we don't focus on any specific
domain we try to carry over the problem
which is common in all this domain so
that it becomes easier for you to
understand because people are from
different domains and from different
backgrounds because some people are from
research side and some people are from
completely into management so we had
made a course in such a way that both
these people get benefited and now i'll
just respond to the other questions
okay
you had a question if the data scientist
goes enough to have a good grasp of the
data scientist
what other resources can we have to
better deeper and practical okay the
simple thing is whenever you get into
this domain it is something big if
you're talking about a data scientist
data scientists role is something very
very reversed he should know what is the
source where the data is getting
generated and he should know how this
data is coming into picture as well as
how he is able to derive out all this
insight using statistical algorithms and
if he's able to derive what insight how
it is how he is going to apply it in
business so that is the more crucial
part
even after after creating your insight
you cannot be able to update in your
business then it is not going to make
any uh it's not going to add any value
to you so we make a structure in such a
way that all these things are being
carried over okay and after this course
you would have a clear picture so
whether to get into completely modeling
or getting into business decisions so
these sort of ideas this particular
course would easily give to everyone
okay and before before coming into your
question i'll just uh answer so
deandra's question okay how analytics
can improve sales i mean i have seven
years of experience in sales four years
of agency students of e-learning skills
okay what opportunities are change of
career i can
first so uh um
you are completed into management side
or
you are into decision making side right
from your question that is what i could
understand okay you are into core sales
yeah so you would know each and every
core point of your sales right so how
sales is happening and how it is done
say for an example if you're talking
about retail sector you know the each
and every part how the sales are
happening but it is highly impossible
for you to figure out in a manual
fashion for an example if you are
holding a small sector say if you hold
10 or 15 store it is easy for you to
understand your complete business and
the way how your business are carried
over but when coming into a greater
picture it is very difficult for our
human mind to have a perception towards
that business right because in all the
cases you are perception sometimes it
works i'm not telling that hundred
percent it doesn't work but in most of
the in most of the cases your intuition
might work or may not work but it should
be true with the data right so that is
what we are looking here so how with
these data how we are going to
understand your business well because
all these data would have a story which
is hidden which you're trying to bring
out and you're trying to deal with your
sales say for an example uh in your
sector just tell me what are the
possible factors that you could think
for sales which is contributing to your
sales
so for an example you are under core
sales say just taken a small example of
a particular problem and tell me how you
would approach without that data
with your manual intuition
i think uh as you have this experience
you would have taken some decisions by
your intuition on looking at your sales
speaker you would have decided some at
some point you would have decided right
any situations in that way okay so if
you have an intuition in that way i can
never tell that it is 100 wrong because
as you have a domain expert in that
particular field you know
better than much better than another
person but what you can do is when
you're comparing your intuition with
data sometimes data would tell you some
different stories which you would never
expect sometimes you would have uh heard
about a popular association like vr and
diaper because people would as a human
being you would never have a thought
that a guy who is getting beard he would
get a diaper it is not a common thing
that a man intuition can make right but
this is a true thing which happens
through numbers so these sort of hidden
stories is what your numbers are trying
to tell so as a data scientist you have
to understand your business as well
because if you're very good at business
you know what is the business problem
there and based on that you can relate
it to the current solution and you can
just
see yourself in future okay how you can
make your business in a better way so it
helps you in taking your decisions in a
more accurate and precise manner
okay
here
they have any questions
and
what other resources can we use
okay uh resources in uh
in terms of resources what is that
you're trying to ask approval other
resources into something like uh
like how well you are we are supporting
in terms of providing the materials is
that your question of what
if that is a
question any books yeah we have our
course material for ourselves for every
algorithms we have our own structure and
we have our own materials which will be
sharing to all the participants when you
enter enrolled into this particular
course everyone will be provided with an
lms access there will provide with all
the possible books plus the course
materials as well as some of the
trainers would provide supplementary
supplementary materials as well so they
would create some slides for better
understanding they will also propose
that and we have a separate community to
talk about your question so at the end
of every session we have a separate
community forum where you can post your
questions all the trainers will be
available there and they'll try to
respond your question so it is something
like uh a platform where you can learn
very easily uh without any hurdle okay
and uh ravi you asked the question so at
the end of the course can i
tell myself as a data scientist yeah
obviously you would get an idea who is a
data scientist because data scientist is
something which you can never attain in
six months or over a year it takes at
least six years or seven years to
understand what is the data scientist
right because it is not an easier job
right now if you are looking at the pay
scale of data centers it is the biggest
thing in market because why people are
doing it because the data right data
scientist guys should know each and
every new corner of your data as well as
a flow as well as the technology which
is emerging in so this course would help
you to understand what is data scientist
as well as you would be equipped to
become a data scientist okay because
even i can never tell that i am a good
data center i've been in this industry
for seven to eight years uh still this
point i can never tell that i'm a good
data center because data centers is
something an art which expands
everywhere it requires all the
technologies to be covered so this would
give you an idea how to travel it and uh
what is your interest and it gives you
an idea about what is analytics and how
you can apply that uh yeah
uh my email id probably whenever you
make a call to the support team they'll
try to connect with me okay even after
the session if you have any question
they try to connect with me and they'll
get back to you okay but that is not a
big deal because i cannot share my mail
id but whenever you make a call uh if
you want to talk with me and my name is
murli okay you can just tell them
so probably whenever i get them if you
have any specific queries to us i'll
just try to respond back and they can
list any good forums to join and get the
kind of issues they get
okay uh you're telling uh what kind of
issues like uh what are all the
analytics problems is that your question
today so obviously in this particular
case what we are trying to do is we
throw you many problem of business case
studies where you are supposedly you are
in a position to figure out the business
problem so we had made case studies or
we have a course lecture in such a way
that will make you do understand the
business okay a website of forums uh
probably with this uh if you want to
understand the code structure you can
just get into complement i think this
particular course have the complete
course structure and we had mentioned
what are all the case studies we use
there and how it is going to impact in
your particular mind or how you can
shift into this domain so those things
are like represented there you can just
call or you can just go through our
simple length site for this particular
course
we had made it uh in an allo directed
way so that you can understand it very
easily okay okay any other questions
okay any the site name so uh you're
telling me any website name to
understand this course or what is it to
understand the basics of analytics right
okay uh i think there is a separate
forum for simply itself we have a
separate forum where we talk about what
is analytics and how it is being
improved even you can just use that
particular forum to understand this
structure or if you get an idea of this
particular course or about the domain of
analytics and probably uh our team also
will share you some of the links so that
you can just go through it to have a
better understanding okay outside of
simply learn
uh i think there are several competitors
i think possibly you can just search it
you can also see
what they are teaching and how how we
are doing it so you can just make a
comparison as well and if you have any
questions during this comparison you can
just comment it
you can ask it asked it to us and there
are many players in market as well you
can just go through their contents and
you can also see our contents
you can also relate it with their things
and this okay uh just problem login
and solutions okay uh in this case
uh if you're like if you're looking at
data analytics problem generally if
you're typing in google you would get
hundreds of sites solving these things
and it depends on specific governments
for retail the problems are something
different and for healthcare it's
something different if you are typing
retail analytics problem skills or
something like that you can just type
and you can get many other websites i'm
not very sure about the specific website
but you would get a lot of points there
okay uh any other questions or any other
doubts regarding this course what if i
take uh like what are the things that i
will get anything like that
i think this clear right about the
structure what we make and if you want
the statistical algorithm and all these
things which is mentioned in your
contents okay uh yes
so this is all about analytics and uh
these are all the pages we covered here
so about the statistical part and uh
looking at the status quo we'll be
covering all probability theory test of
significance and these are all the
common things
which is handle in each and every phase
and then we'll see a different machine
learning algorithm as well as v tool
component oriented
so how we can do all this transformation
and all this process in terms of r as
well as sas so we have split it into
different lessons
and uh if you want like you can also go
through the site
i think simplyland had provided the site
where they had mentioned the course
content i think uh here this particular
link will tell you what are the topics
that we are covering supply chain
analytics example web analytics and
applications of all these cases and this
is the core structure that we have
introduction of our art programming data
structure
data visualization graduation and all
this algorithm
and basic analytic techniques of sas and
excel so this is only for r and apart
from this the same structure we have for
sax as well as excel
okay and if you want i'll just share
this link
i guess you would have seen all those
links
but anyway i'll share this with you
okay you can just go ahead to understand
the course structure
yeah these are all the things that we
are
going to see in our course so you can go
ahead with these topics and even then if
you have any questions you can just call
our technical team whereas they'll try
to answer it or if not if you want to
make a private call to me or something
like that you can just make the request
to them so they'll i'll just try to
attend the call and i can respond back
to your questions if there is any
specific question to ask
say
uh code related or algorithm related you
can just go through this link here we
have clearly mentioned what are the
things that we are discussing now
and you can also see with the
competitors as well how good they are
also doing and how we are doing and if
you're not if you have any questions
from their structure and our structure
you can ask us
we'll try to solve it
okay okay soon yeah okay any other
questions yeah so basically just go
through the structure and try to read
about these things and uh just go and
explore okay how about certification
yeah so certification is something after
this course uh you will be in a position
to submit your case studies where during
the session itself we try to
solve all those case studies because
every week after the session we try to
solve the case studies as well
so it is not a big deal so once your
first get over in six weeks so even if
you take two three days time you can
solve all this case study so that you
can just get your certificate by
submitting it and we will also help you
in terms of solving the first case
studies if you are stuck at some point
okay first if you are stuck at some
point of time we try to help this out
any other questions
okay six ways is not that for self-paced
learning yeah
six weeks are not a constraint because
we have a open lbc platform say for
example uh there are many trainers in
this particular class
say if i am a trainer and you are
attending my sessions and unfortunately
in a week you're not able to attend my
session so probably what you can do is
you can join the same third week or the
fourth week of another trainer so you
have an access period so this lbc
something you can just join in any one
of these sessions
you can if you're missing out some of my
classes you would get a recorded session
and even if you want to connect with
other badges you can also do it okay so
these are all options we provide so
applicable options okay with it
it is not for both self-paced and uh the
online course okay uh is there any
deadline for assignment in self learning
there is no such deadline so whenever
you are
whenever you are like completing your
case studies you can just uh provide
those documents you can get your
certificates and if you want it uh
very urgently you have to complete your
courses very very quickly and you have
to submit it and i don't think all these
case studies are uh very easier to solve
when you are going through the structure
in a proper way so because at the end of
all these sessions we'll give you an
idea how to approach this as well
so if you are trying to solve it at the
end of every session that will be very
easy for you any other questions and one
thing before you take up just go through
the course material
just get satisfied with this and if you
have any questions
always you can just contact simplylearn
we're there to help you out
okay how valuable simply learn
certificate is or any other organization
to take from the exam
and do your thing uh
this particular simply learn is the
world's eighth best training center okay
the first eight bus training center and
you and almost like uh there are 600 or
700 professions who had take up taken up
this our sas course and even personally
i had handled almost 300 participants so
whereas they are in good positions and
they had shifted their dominant which
you can go through our reviews as well
so people had a good talk about that so
this is actually a valid thing and
people even in industries they recognize
simply learn certifications
because we are worldwide into market
any other questions
okay so all your questions are answered
is that clear for everyone
so uh yeah that's it so probably will uh
wind up this demo session
and if you have any further questions
you can ask to our simply learn team
which you can just give a call to them
and they'll they're there to help you
out and if you're like stuck at some
point or if you have a question what is
it and how we are going to do this
approach and obviously you can see the
help of something and even where we
trainers are there to help you out
okay okay share today thanks thanks a
lot thanks everyone
so we will end this session
you